Problem number 18.
The average arithmetic
mean of x and y is k.
So the average, so x plus
y/2 is k, right?
That's the average of x
and y is equal to k.
Which of the following is the
average of x, y and z?
So they want to know what x plus
y-- so the average of x,
y, and z is, you add up
all the numbers and
you divide by 3.
They want to know in
terms of k and z.
So if we could substitute for
x plus y, then we'd be done.
So multiplying this equation by
2, we get x plus y is equal
to 2k, right?
Just multiply both sides by 2.
And then x plus y is 2k.
So let's just substitute
2k here for x plus y.
So then you just get
2k plus z/3.
That's the average of x, y
and z: 2k plus z/3, and
that is choice A.
Problem 19.
We have a neat drawing here.
Let me see if I can draw this.
Let's see, we have a circle,
and then we have a triangle
inside of that.
Well it's not really inside of
it, it kind of does something
like-- let's see, the triangle
goes like that.
And the other line kind of
goes-- Oh, oh, close enough.
Close enough.
I think you get the point.
It actually kind of touches
at the bottom there.
This should be touching
at the bottom.
And then we have-- oh, we
have another line that
goes down like this.
All right.
OK.
This is O, Y, X, W, Z.
This is W.
We can do a better
color on W, OK?
That's O, V, all right.
In the figure above, triangle
X, Y, Z is equilateral--
that's good to know-- with
side of length 2.
So this side is 2, this
side is 2, and this
whole side is 2.
If w, y is the diameter of the
circle with center O-- so w,
y, this is the diameter of the
circle with center O-- then
the area of the circle
is-- fascinating.
So essentially, we just need to
figure out what the height
of this line is, because if we
know the length of this, we
can figure out the area.
Because that's the diameter,
we'd know the radius, and we'd
use pi r squared.
So how do we figure that out?
Well, this is an equilateral
triangle, and so that means
all of the angles
are 60 degrees.
So that's 60, this
is 60 degrees.
And now this whole angle up here
is going to be 60, but we
split it exactly
in two, right?
So this angle is going to be 30
degrees and this angle is
30 degrees.
And if you don't believe me,
how else do we know that?
Well they tell us that this
is a right angle, right?
This is a right angle, this
is a 90 degree angle.
So that's how we know this was
actually split in two, because
this is 90, this is 60, and they
have to add up to 180.
So this angle up here is 30.
So I think you are going to see
now that this is a classic
30, 60, 90 triangle, right?
If this side up here is 2, then
we know that the side
opposite the 30 degree side
is 1/2 the hypotenuse.
This side is the hypotenuse
right here.
The corresponding side to the
30 degree side, or the
opposite to the 30 degree side,
is 1/2 the hypotenuse.
So this is 2, this is 1.
And that also makes sense,
because this is a symmetric
triangle, and this w is the
midpoint, because it's
perpendicular and these
angles the same.
So this would also be 1.
So 1, and 1, and 2,
1 plus 1 is 2.
So that makes sense as well.
And then we know-- and if you
forget this, they actually
give you the formula at the
beginning of every SAT exam--
that the side opposite the 60
degree side-- which is the
side we're trying to figure
out-- that square root of 3
times this side-- so square root
of 3 times this is what?
Well it's square root of
3 times 1, which is
square root of 3.
And if you don't believe this,
you could try the Pythagorean
theorem, right?
Square root of 3 squared plus 1
squared is equal to-- well 3
plus 1, which is equal to 4,
which is equal to 2 squared.
Which is equal to hypotenuse
squared.
So we figured out this diameter
right here is
square root of 3.
The whole thing is
If the whole thing is square
root of 3, what is the radius?
The radius is going
to be 1/2 of that.
The radius is 1/2 of that,
so the radius is
square root of 3/2.
And now we're ready to
figure out the area.
Area is equal to pi r squared.
And they give you this
formula too at the
beginning of the SAT.
So area is equal
to pi times the
square root of 3/2 squared.
And that equals pi times square
root of 3 squared is
3/-- and then 2 squared
is 4, so 3/4 pi.
And 3/4 pi is choice C.
Image, clear image, invert
colors, all right.
Problem 20.
We're already at the end
of this section.
Problem 20, when 15 is divided
by the positive integer k, the
remainder 3.
So 15 divided by k has
a remainder of 3.
I'm lazy.
For how many different values
of k is this true?
So when 15 is divided by k,
you have a remainder of 3.
Interesting, OK.
Actually the easiest thing to do
is say well, 15 divided by
k is going to be, essentially--
Well the easiest
way-- I'm just trying to think
of whether we should just do
it by brute force.
We can actually just do it by
brute force, because it says k
is a positive integer, right?
So what values of k work?
Well does k equal 1 work?
When 15 is divided by 1,
there's no remainder.
So k 1 does not work.
k equals 2?
Actually, let's just do
it. k remainder 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, right?
It's going to go all
the way up to 15.
You know, we could
keep trying.
So when 1, the remainder is 0.
2 goes into 15 7 times with
a remainder of 1.
3 goes into 15 with
a remainder of 0.
4 goes into 15 with a remainder
of 3, right?
Because 4 gets to 12, and then
you have a remainder of 3.
5 has a remainder of 0.
6, once again, 6 gets to
12, and then it has a
remainder of 3.
So 6 works.
So 4 and 6 work.
7 has a remainder of 1, right?
7, 14 remainder of 1.
And then if you just did 8,
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 8 has a
remainder of 7.
9 has a remainder of 6.
10 has a remainder of 5.
11 has a remainder
of 4, right?
15 divided by 11 is
1, remainder of 4.
12 has a remainder of
3, so 12 works.
13 has a remainder of 2.
14 has a remainder of 1.
And then 15 has no
remainder again.
So the numbers that work
for k are 12, 6, and 4.
So it was essentially the
factors of-- well all right, I
can't actually say that.
Well, we just did it by brute
force and those are the 3 k's
that work for this problem.
So the answer is choice C.
I'm trying to think if there's
a faster, elegant
way of doing this.
But this actually didn't
take too much time.
But anyway, that's all
for this section.
I'll see you in the
next SAT section.